(light music)
- Today I'll be trying an
acupressure mat from Amazon.
- My upper back is real fucked up.
- I look at multiple different screens
and I do get a lot of neck pain.
- I have something called
degenerative disk disease
which sounds like way more
serious than it actually is.
- I've had chronic back pain
for the last four years.
I do suffer from moderate scoliosis
which I've had for about 18 years.
- I go to Chinatown and I have them
like really just get into it.
- I've been in lots of
different physical therapy.
I've tried prescription pain medication.
- I'd say I'm at like a six out of ten.
- I've only been at work for two hours
and my pain level is already a seven
so I'm really hoping that this works.
- I'm like so open to trying
things to relieve my back pain.
- The fact that it's from
Amazon is fine with me
because I love Amazon.
I trust it. I think.
(beeping)
- I mean I'm putting my hand on here
and it's already stinging.
- Should I take my shirt off or...
- I imagine the end is where I put my head
and then I just kind of lay down.
- I want maximum effectiveness
from this high quality
Amazon technology.
(light music)
What's it like?
Oooooh.
- Oh!
- It just feels prickly.
- Like a massage, like a
bunch of fingers all together
going all in my back.
- It kind of feels like
lying on a Brillo pad.
- It feels good on my back.
It does not feel good on the head.
- Like the best head
scratch I've ever had.
- It's like getting all
up in the cranial areas.
Now I'm feeling kind of relaxed.
- I'm curious to know
what this would be like
with no shirt on 'cuz I'd
imagine it hurts a little bit.
- Right.
- It seems like there's a lot
of little things on my head.
It's like little ants crawling.
- Ow.
- Oh my God.
I don't think I could ever sleep on this.
- I don't know why I started doing this.
- This thing here I think
is really doing well
especially if you just
move around a little bit.
- Ow.
- It's really hurting my ear.
- I do like a little dancing.
- I prefer laying down not on this.
- I've spent like thousands
of dollars on pain relief
so for me 40 bucks is like,
yup, I'll try it.
- I hope I feel better when I stand up.
- Oh.
- Oh, owww.
Are there marks on my back?
- I think it was relaxing but
you all seem concerned now.
- I feel like I just took a nap.
- I don't feel that different.
- You know, a little more relaxed,
a little more limber.
- It feels like when you
sit like on a lounge chair
with no beach towel on it
and you know that you have
like lines in your back.
I have that but like times a thousand
'cuz it's a lot of little holes.
- I don't feel as much neck pain.
My mobility is definitely improved.
- I probably won't try this
again just because for me
and my specific back condition
I don't think it will be helpful.
I think other means
will be more effective.
- I think I'd purchase it.
$40 seems like not that much to pay
if you consider having to
go and pay for a massage
or pay for an acupuncturist.
- I would spend my money on naked yoga
or like burritos 'cuz
those are relaxing as well.
I might still be trying to
steal the mat afterwards.
- The day after I used
the mat I woke up feeling
basically no pain at all.
I don't know if it was
just a coincidence or not
but I might change my mind about this mat.
(light music)
♫ We're here to play our part